in the beginning
there was nothing then bang
our universe emerged in an explosion of
light and energy or
did it let's shed some light on this
so how fast is the universe expanding
will the universe and everything in it
ever die
and why could our universe have existed
before the big bang
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the big bang wasn't the beginning of
the universe
the universe is big like
astronomically big current theories
say that it all began 13.7
billion years ago and that everything we
see
came from an infinitely dense point
called a singularity but where did that
singularity come from there might be
more to it than you think and
maybe the universe never really had a
beginning
the big bang theory tells us that after
the universe emerged from a singularity
it started expanding and fast
this is known as the cosmic inflation
phase
and when i say fast i mean fast
one moment there was a single point half
the size of a dna molecule
a fraction of a second later it expanded
to 10.6
light years across this is how the
universe we know and love
today ended up being relatively stable
with
hardly any density fluctuations
but these small density fluctuations
are the reason why we have galaxies and
stars
when we start talking about distances
this big
we can use the term parsec which is a
distance
of 3.26 light years
a megaparsec is a million times bigger
currently the universe is still
expanding it's expanding
at a rate of 73.5 kilometers per second
per megaparsec that means that for every
3.26
million light years an object was away
from us
it's moving 73.5 kilometers per second
faster but there is a problem
if the universe keeps expanding for
billions
and billions of years at some point
it could enlarge too much as in
all the energy in it would dissipate and
then our universe
wouldn't exist anymore but what if i
told you there's a new theory in town
scientists are calling it the big bounce
it's the combination of the big bang and
the big crunch
the big crunch is when the expansion of
the universe
goes in reverse and the universe
collapses
you could say it's the exact opposite of
the big bang
the big bounce theory says that the
universe will
eventually start to contract and when it
does
instead of reaching a singularity it
tunnels into another expanding universe
just imagine a balloon expanding
and contracting and each cycle would be
our universe starting over again so
you might be asking well how is this
different from the big bang
well this theory is different because of
what scientists call
the scalar field the scalar field would
make
the gravitational field exert negative
pressure
stopping our universe's contraction then
the expansion would begin all over again
if this theory is right it could have
serious consequences for our universe
first off it would mean that our
universe would have
no beginning and no end
it would be reborn every time it
collapsed
and if you think about it that would
make our universe
infinite maybe not in size but in
time now if you think
you could stick around to see this well
that's probably not going to happen
that's because
once the universe contracts it wouldn't
be the same
for instance matter would be distributed
differently so most likely
the new version of the universe wouldn't
be
like ours and it could be
so different that the laws of physics
wouldn't be like the laws we know the
universe
could emerge in such a way that no stars
or
planets would form or maybe the universe
would form so that
complex life forms could flourish
would that be amazing or what so
if we take a look at the big picture
what does this
all mean for us well not much would
change
in our everyday lives all the changes
would be
so far in the future that they won't
affect us
whatever they are when it comes to the
future of the universe
we know so little that anything could
happen
so we'll need to keep looking at the
stars as
the answers are out there somewhere
uh you know what else is out there black
holes
what would happen if you fell into one
of them
well that's a story for another
what if